[Musique]
quelle heure est-il sur la lune au
moment où on se parle ouais bah on se
pose rarement pour pas dire jamais la
question même qu'on se demande pourquoi
vous voulez qu'on vous parle de ça ce
matin mais parce que l'Agence spatiale
européenne voudrait établir un fuseau
horaire sur la lune dès maintenant la
strophysicien Robert Lamontagne est là
pour nous expliquer le souhait des
Européens certainement qu'on peut tous
en bénéficier c'est sûr que si je vais à
Paris je sais quand j'arriverai combien
d'heures je dois ajouter alors local
alors quelle est l'utilité de faire un
peu le même genre de processus là pour
si jamais on voit sur la Lune par
exemple
mais en fait c'est que on va retourner
sur la Lune de manière beaucoup plus
fréquente dans les 10 15 prochaines
années tant d'émissions habitées par
exemple le projet Artémis qui prévoit le
retour d'astronautes pour 2025 mais
aussi de nombreux missions robotisées
par les agences spatiales nationales
NASA agence spatiale d'Europe même le
Canada mais aussi des entreprises
privées et donc il va falloir coordonner
les activités de tous ces véhicules de
tout ce personnel en orbite autour de la
Lune sur la lune elle-même et donc il
faudrait avoir un système qui est un peu
l'équivalent des fuseaux horaires sur la
terre qui permet entre autres de
coordonner toutes nos activités ça va de
la navigation
maritime ou aérienne au système de
d'échange bancaire le GPS dans votre
téléphone donc on veut avoir un
équivalent sur la Lune
juste comme ça ça doit pas être simple
de prévoir ça parce que la Lune n'est
pas fait une rotation sur elle-même qui
tourne autour de la Terre qui elle-même
fait une rotation sur elle-même et qui
tourne autour du soleil alors ça fait
beaucoup de calcul et à prévoir
tout à fait c'est un problème assez ça a
l'air banal mais c'est un problème
complexe bon historiquement évidemment
sur la terre on s'est fié au soleil
n'est-ce pas les premiers cadran
solaires et donc
la rotation de la Terre qui se fait en
24 heures on a défini 24 fuseau horaire
à peu près d'une heure chacun mais sur
la lune l'équivalent d'une journée
définie par le soleil sur la lune ça
dure 29 jours et demi donc comment on va
établir des fuseaux horaires sur la lune
c'est moins simple il y a aussi si on
veut faire un calcul extrêmement précis
sur Terre par exemple on tient compte
des effets de la relativité telles que
calculé par Einstein il y a un siècle et
donc on a juste les horloges sur la lune
on devra faire la même chose mais parce
que la vitesse de la Lune n'est pas la
même que la terre parce que la masse de
la Lune n'est pas la même que la terre
il les décalage seront un peu différents
et entre autres entre autres sur la lune
le temps avance 56
milliardième de seconde plus rapidement
que sur la terre c'est c'est pas très
grave pour la vie de tous les jours mais
pour les systèmes de navigation ça
devient extrêmement important si vous
voulez vous poser à un endroit très
précis sur la lune oui oui je comprends
et on veut pas trop on veut pas faire
d'erreur à cet égard dans le moment le
quand on entend vous savez j'entends ces
conversations quelquefois on a des
extraits de NASA on sait qu'on va
réveiller par exemple les pilotes ou les
astronautes les cosmonautes au son d'une
certaine musique pour un anniversaire
des choses dans le moment là on règle
leur journée comment est-ce que c'est
chronométrer à partir de l'endroit où la
fusée est partie ou comment on détermine
qui est 6h du matin quand on fait le
tour de la terre comme ça pendant 120
jours
alors donc dans le cas des astronautes
dans la station spatiale internationale
on s'est entendu pour utiliser ce qu'on
appelle le Time universel donc
essentiellement le méridien Grinch en
Angleterre donc c'est le c'est ce qui
coordonne le temps donc les différentes
agences au Canada aux États-Unis ou en
Europe qui parle à leurs astronautes
fonctionnent sur leur degré niches
lorsqu'on va sur la lune ou sur Mars
présentement on utilise le temps local
du centre de contrôle qui pilote le
robot la sonde ou des choses comme ça et
donc ça pose problème par exemple si
l'Agence spatiale européenne envoie un
robot sur la lune et l'agence américaine
en envoyant quelle heure on va utiliser
il va parler à qui et à quelle heure
n'est-ce pas mais c'est vrai
qu'effectivement on va avoir deux robots
qui sont mandatés pour faire une job
ensemble mais ils seront pas
synchronisés à la même heure si je
comprends bien exactement
problème technique et bien on en apprend
tous les jours comme ça vous pensez que
ce serait réglé ça quand on va aller sur
la Lune en mission habitée le 25 26
ben il y a déjà des discussions en cours
présentement et on a l'avantage
maintenant de préparer ce système de
fuseau horaire lunaire si on peut dire
avant qu'on en ait besoin alors que sur
Terre on l'établi après qu'on en ait eu
besoin donc on a un avantage ici et puis
on sait comment le faire et on sait
comment le faire on va très bien
monsieur la montagne merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de parler ce matin
à la prochaine
ça fait plaisir au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI